So this is my,
actually,
even though I'm native to Prague,
and I've lived here on and off for some,
well half of my life,
I've never given a talk at a conference in Prague.
So this is my first time in Prague.
And uh I usually do talks
at automated reasoning conferences.
So,
so I'm,
I'm curious like what this will turn into
and what you A G I people are about
and like,
definitely ask questions if you,
if you don't understand something,
etcetera.
I um so be be before I first
get into it.
I because of the location,
I was giving two months ago a talk in
Pittsburgh at the conference in honor
of Tom Hall who is the guy who proved the Khol conjecture.
So K conjecture,
I will be talking about it as a conjecture,
mathematical conjecture in geometry about stacking the optimal packing of
balls in space.
And that's been for 400 years,
an open conjecture which Tom proved and he also proved it
formally on,
on a computer basically.
So,
um so there,
there was a huge conference for his sixth birthday and on that
occasion,
I sort of digged up uh what was happening
in Prague some 400 years ago when Kepler
and Brahe and all these guys,
they are doing,
doing that research here.
And basically what happened then,
like with the Kepler loss and Kepler conjecture and all
these exact measurements which had,
and which led Kepler and Galileo and later guys
to what they did is to some extent,
the beginning of what is called the scientific revolution.
Uh So,
so if you still have time here,
I I strongly sort of encourage you to,
to take a look at all these places like at the Prague Castle,
et cetera where these people really worked.
And uh to,
to some extent,
it's,
it's really the beginning of uh sort
of matheos like which like Newton to
his princi pr and,
and talk to the real development of mathematical physics
and like in the end to all these tools which uh
which sort of basically and with the development of computer
and the origin of artificial intelligence.
So to some extent,
I'm not saying this is the only place where it began.
But to some extent,
you are in a place where a lot of that process
began 400 years ago.
So now I'll get into micro propaganda.
Um So no one shall drive us from the semantic A I paradise of computer understandable
math and science.
Um So I will explain in a,
in a bit for,
for those who don't know the pun uh
this is the outline of the talk.
So I'll say something about this sort of
high level motivation for basically doing artificial
intelligence over uh semantic,
a large semantic corporal of which uh
formal mathematics is today.
Really the primal representative.
Then I'll tell you what is basically computer understandable mathematics.
What is formal mathematics?
I'll,
I'll show you some demo of how,
how the system works.
Uh Like how well they are used by uh people today.
And then I'll go into some details of particular
systems,
how we are basically combining machine learning and
like deduction and reasoning tools into some sort of bigger
A I tools which combine reasoning and learning.
And so,
so if the last bit is is this out of formalization at the at the
bottom,
which is uh sort of um branch of this
research where we take informal knowledge at the moment,
informal mathematical knowledge,
but it should be applicable to hard sciences in general
and try to automatically translate it into this
beautiful world of semantic computer understandable
mathematics on which we can do all these sort of cool
experiments.
So this is the very high level
motivation.
And that's basically the,
the,
the question,
the big question here is how do we automate mathematical and uh
scientific thinking?
Um And um on,
on one hand,
uh when you uh when you do mathematics and when you
do like hard science,
you,
you know that you are doing a lot of pattern matching
and analogizing and induction from examples that you have so
that you have seen and learned.
But on the other hand,
you also know that without especially in mathematics,
without bringing your ideas to complete
proof,
you basically have nothing and you could be very badly mistaken.
And obviously there are all these complicated feedback loops
between our intuition and
the reasoning processes and the sort of final
deduction processes and sometimes the intuition can be clearly
wrong.
Like when you look at examples
from physics,
like something like relativity or quantum mechanics is
extremely unintuitive,
but you sort of force yourself to go there by using deduction basically.
And then based on that your intuition changes and
you are able to come up with more and more complicated models of
reality.
So so to get there,
we clearly are using a lot of previous knowledge,
both for this sort of learning of our intuition,
but also for drawing facts from the huge knowledge basis which
we have observed.
And we would like to develop such methods,
such technology on computers,
obviously,
we would like to have very strong assistance for doing math and for
doing science.
And that should be one of your goals,
right?
Like you,
you should,
if you want to reach singularity or general A I,
you you should strive to uh develop tools that do science on,
on the sort of human or superhuman level.
So,
so when I started to do that I basically looked what would be good.
Um Corp which would be usable
both for a very precise deduction when sort of
the knowledge isn't imprecise at the bottom.
And you can't really do a lot of reasoning chains and long reasoning
chase,
but also a corpora which would be big so that
you could do the stuff that we do,
you could do all sorts of learning from,
from the corpora,
like learning from a textbook of math or a textbook of physics.
And actually like 20 years ago when I started to
look at this,
there already were these large libraries of formal
proof and formal theories.
And that's sort of this field of formalization of mathematics,
of doing mathematics fully in a computer,
understandable and computer verified way.
And that,
that's basically the,
the sort of field uh where I'm working on like
developing the sort of strong A I uh tools on on top
of this cor.
Um So,
so this is um the P um the P
uh is on the right hand side.
So there are these two uh two guys like one is called
Po Carre and one is called Hilbert.
And this,
this picture by the way comes from a very nice book called Logic Comics,
An Epic Search For Truth,
which is about the life of Bertrand Russell,
which I really recommend to anybody who wants some sort of introduction
to basically how mathematics and logic and also
computers and formal reasoning are developed in the last century.
So it's an extremely good intro to
that.
And so so at the,
at the start of last century,
there were these 22 great mathematicians,
Henri Pore and David Hilbert,
who had a very different view of
how,
what mathematics is and how mathematics should proceed and which should be the
things uh mathematicians should be doing.
So,
so Hilbert was a part of,
of a process,
um which sort of goes back sort of to,
to Leibniz at least to Leibnitz.
Um the mathematics was really put uh
on a very solid uh logical
basis.
So so,
but basically,
all of mathematics have been in the previous century
put on mm on foundations
where everything can be derived basically
in a way where a computer can check all the
inferences in very advanced mathematical truths.
I'll show you some examples at the start of the centuries.
Obviously,
there was no computers like computers sort of developed
as a,
as a sort of in some sense accident of,
of,
of this process of symbolic logic.
Like during when he proposed the universe T machine,
he actually was proving something
about real numbers,
right?
And,
and Panka was this great sort of last
renaissance renaissance guy who understood everything who understood
all of math and a lot of physics,
et cetera.
And he argued that this formalism that this
attempt to bring mathematics on solid solid
mechanized footing will kill kill the
mathematical spirit,
kill the mathematical intrusion,
which he was uh she was uh very,
very good at.
Uh So,
so,
so here of this book,
Science and Method,
um he actually analyzes his own thinking processes.
So it's sort of interesting even from,
for all sorts of A I people today still.
And he has all these sentences there,
like and in demonstration itself,
logic is not all the true mathematical reasoning is real induction.
So it's like people still quarrel what he means by induction there.
But you could understood it as an opposite to deduction.
And in some sense,
I very much agree with him,
like in,
in theory improving and improving hard theorems,
we we really need to make the theory
improving algorithms and machines uh do these
things to,
to sort of learn from examples and analogize et cetera,
et cetera.
Oh Then uh I,
so I I will also mention this guy who
in some sense is very much on the Hilbert side of the wall,
at least in the beginning,
like he is the guy who basically brings,
brings out the universal computing machines.
And uh he,
he's so uh does the does the great result about
undecidable and halting problem,
et cetera?
But like he,
he basically like in his later work also really
establishes the field of A I,
right?
Like he writes this paper in 1950 about computing machinery and intelligence.
And despite all these negative results which have been used
forever in the last century.
And they still are used to tell people,
machines cannot do mathematics because of turing undecidable
because of Gal theorem and blah blah blah.
Well,
already in 1950 he writes in this paper,
we may hope that machines will eventually compete with man in all purely intellectual fields.
So then he sort of basically contradicts all the people like
Penrose Slater who would claim that these sort of hard
19 thirties results are something which prevents machines from doing
mathematics.
And actually in this paper,
he already has a chapter on learning machines.
So,
so so machine learning is in some latest offshoot,
but it really started in the first paper on A I
in 19 fifties where he,
for example,
proposes taking chess and like teaching
uh teaching algorithms and training algorithms to
play chess better and better.
So you can,
you can really see that this is something which materialized heavily with the recent
alpha go or alpha alpha zero stuff.
Oh So,
so,
so basically he himself already like,
like the two things he's saying there can be combined to like,
why wouldn't we do this with mathematics which is sort of infinitely more
expressive than just playing chess or of playing go.
And if we can do it,
and he obviously didn't know that at the time if he can do it with chess and go,
I wouldn't be able to train thinking machines
which work in this very expressive formalism which mathematics
is using and which basically we believe that all of hard
science can be reduced to.
So that's the sort of general aspect,
like in some sense,
you could say that solving goal or solving chess is still sort of very narrow
A I because it's just some sort of NP complete game or whatever.
But if you can do a similar thing with,
let's say first all of theory or any sufficiently rich foundation,
which can capture all of mathematics.
And then first of all,
you,
you will be able to do mm
superhuman or assistance for
doing not just math but all these sciences like physics and
computer science which reduce,
reduce mathematics.
So that's the motivation and
just one more quote from Turin,
he basically in this quote for at each stage when one is using a
logical system,
there is a very large number of alternative steps and which is permitted to apply so far as obedience
to the rules of the logical system is concerned,
these choices make the difference between a brilliant and a food reason and not the difference between a sound
and a fallacious one.
So here you can see that he already distinguishes
between what is logically sound and what is allowed by the
hardcore mathematical formalism.
And the sort of A I part there,
the sort of intelligence part there where the logical calculus
allows you to do many possible steps but only some of them are the good ones and
obviously you would like to be doing the hood
ones.
So,
so these are the sort of classical
people and classical motivations.
Why would you combine learning and reasoning today?
Well,
the point number one is that it's really practically useful.
So uh there,
there are all these verification projects uh today.
Uh like it,
it's sort of um very much um
exploded in the,
let's say,
last decade um where people really
cannot verify very large mathematical proofs,
like the proof of the Kepler conjecture in any other way than
using computers.
Because humans simply do not scale to verification of such humongous
mathematical truths.
And there are a couple of such things like the formal proof of the other or
five Thomson theorem.
So,
so it's really a technology where today's
mathematics is gradually being made fully
computer understandable and fully computer verified to the level of
sometimes very nontrivial theorems and truths.
And the the sort of commercial or industrial part of this
is uh software and hardware verification.
So,
so basically for,
for both mathematics and for software and hardware verification,
the the tools currently which go
really deep,
which really gives you the formal certainty that something will work and
something is correct are basically the same,
they are called the formal proof assistants or interactive theory pros.
So again,
like the,
this is like uh this year at flock like uh
one month ago in Oxford,
they the Amazon people have hired a group of like
20 to 30 strong people to do to
do formal verification of their call services because
like American Banks and CIA and whoever
don't want to be hacked by unfriendly parties.
And the only way how to ensure that is to give a formal proof that your design and
your software is correct.
And these are huge proofs also and the same is happening with other companies like
Facebook has this inferred tool and Google
has something,
etcetera.
So,
so,
so the more you can automate reasoning,
the more you can help people who do these sort of formal verification projects,
the better,
the more efficient that they are.
And typically you need to handle big theories.
When you deal with this,
typically,
these are projects which have like thousands of definitions and
tens of thousands of lemmas in them,
which you need to use efficiently.
And obviously,
the other part is,
is all this blue sky uh motivation that we might uh sort
of get uh to,
to some version of strong A I if we,
if you learn how to,
how to combine learning and reasoning um efficiently.
Uh so,
so the,
the,
the sort of thing which we have been doing has been following this plan where
we sort of first made a lot of these formal
thought corpora accessible to various reasoning
and learning A I tools.
And that sort of started to happen like 15 years
ago,
but it's still happening for various large formal
corpora.
And then,
then the next thing we,
we,
we have been doing is to like,
try all sorts of like standard.
Uh So a TP stands for automated theorem proving uh tools and,
and standard machine learning tools and,
and,
and their combinations to,
to,
to make them prove harder and harder theorems from,
from,
from these libraries.
And we are not very good yet.
But like if by some accident,
we improve,
then we can always create harder and harder problems.
OK.
So this,
this was the intro,
the motivation thing and I'll try to give you a sample
of what I'm talking about when I'm saying formal or computer understandable mathematics.
So,
so,
so as I said,
it's a result of this program of ology
of bringing logic to mathematics basically,
which goes back at least to Leibniz,
all these people like Russell and Frager and Hilbert.
Uh And uh in,
in some sense,
it means that in instead of some sort of vague
abstract mathematical manipulations which I don't know,
maybe some of you uh delegate to some Black magic mathematicians who
do some crazy operations in their head.
Everything is uh sort of brought down to very simple
symbolic manipulation.
So,
so that's,
that's the sort of log as uh program which has really
been carried out in the last century.
And as I said,
by the way,
this led also to the rise of the computers and,
and formal mathematics is an
attempt to,
to basically combine these two things to use.
The fact that mathematics has been reduced fully to symbolic
manipulation and to really employ
computers to do it for you to either verify it or to even help you find
new proofs.
And like in some at an A G I slash singularity
conference,
a good um a good analogy which occurred to me
for those who,
who know this is when G's book Rainbow's End,
which is sort of a nice uh uh science fiction,
which is not so far away from today.
There people have something which they call the secure hardware player,
which is some sort of un hackable secure layer of all
hardware where you cannot get through.
I mean,
when you have some sort of mathematical certainty that some bad things will not happen.
So basically,
basically this is what formal or computer understandable proof gives you,
it gives you a full mathematical logical certainty that
a particular system behaves according to its specification.
So it's the sort of we have nothing.
But at the moment,
basically,
that's the ultimate certainty that we have today.
So conceptually form of math is really very simple.
So you sort of write all your axioms and theorems in some sort of
computer pars form.
So it's similar to programming languages.
And then you write some sort of inference rules which where the
computer can apply operations like deriving
one formula from two other formulas like using mode respondents or
whatever the favorite inference rule.
And then you use a computer to check the proofs which are sort of written
sufficiently in sufficient detail to allow them to understand
how the inference rules operate.
Etc in practice,
it's,
it's sort of hard,
it's been a field developing for some 50 years now.
And there are quite a few approaches
and uh I,
I'd say for,
for a long time,
for example,
the mathematicians didn't really buy into it.
Uh and some extremely opposed to it.
So for example,
Michael Atia,
who is this very senior a guy
who has fields medals and all of that and has
done incredible work in the last century in mathematics and
geometry was very opposed to it.
Uh until let's say in the last decade,
people really made these breakthroughs,
these very large proofs like the proof of the capital conjecture or the proof of the fight
uh theorem.
So the the situation is really changing quite a bit in the
last decade in the sense that mathematicians are
sort of coming on board and exploring ways how they could start to
collaborate with computers in the sense of verifying their proofs basically.
Um So,
so here is an example worked out by
my colleague from the Elon's fre weed egg showing the
irrationality of the square root of two.
Uh So he,
he always shows people this sort of informal proof from hard
and right,
uh which is a proof by contradiction and sort of
ascribed to Pythagoras.
As you,
you may know the story about Pythagoras being unhappy that there are things
which are not rational.
So you assume that the square root of two is rational,
then you sort of get this equation A squared equals to B square root
which is soluble in integers A B,
so that the G they are called prime basically.
So it's this bracket A B equals one.
And then you continue saying,
well,
that means the A A squared is even and therefore A is even.
And then you express A as to C and then you rewrite it and then you infer that B is
also even.
And this is a contradiction to your assumption that A and B are a COP
prime.
So they didn't have any common divisor.
So that's the sort of classical classical proof written in natural
language mathematics.
Uh So this is the first example of a formal
proof which is sort of very um similar
or related to,
to the informal one.
So,
so,
so this is really something which you,
which is written in a programming language.
The programming language is called Mizar.
It's a sort of formal formal proof language and
this is all uh fully passable by the Mizar
group checker.
So it will understand um these uh keywords
like uh theorem and proof and assume
um and it will also understand like the uh formulas
written here.
And,
uh this is not a fool proof in bizarre
because it's missing uh justifications.
So,
so here on the right hand side,
you,
you would typically justify,
uh,
like for example,
why,
why did you go from a squared being even to a being
even?
So,
so here,
here you would have to say something like by the RM five from,
uh,
I don't know theory X or something like that.
But um this,
this is sort of already the proof checker will at
this point tell you,
I don't understand why a particular inference has been justified because it's
missing.
But it will tell you,
yes,
I can parse all the formulas and I can parse all the
sort of natural deduction that they like this assume and consider etcetera.
And I can see that if I could justify all these
tiny steps there,
then indeed,
this is a proof of what I,
what I'm trying to show of the fact that square of two is rational.
This particular misar proof
style is called declarative because you are sort of writing down
the statements.
Like similarly to the informal
proof.
Here is an example of a totally different system which is very non declarative.
It's called procedural proof style or tactical proof style.
So the system is called whole light.
And uh it has it again,
it takes um your your statement which you want to prove
and then it applies all sorts of tactics to uh to the
statement.
So,
so it applies some sort of simplification technique uh with some names of
definitions which you sort of might want to expand and then you
apply some rewriting tactic and some discharge tactic,
et cetera.
And so,
so this is sort of very
imperative way of.
So when you are writing the proof in the whole light,
you do see what's your current goal and how have you transformed the conjecture which you
wanted to prove?
But this sort of proof is not really readable.
So it's called this tactical,
it has some advantages like you can use really
like powerful programmed tactics to do the various goal
transformations.
And the last one I'll show you is this Isabel Hole which is sort
of a combination of the declarative and and the more
procedural style where the the basis is very similar to,
to the declarative misar proof style.
But you,
you have these um there is sort of procedural
complicated commands like this auto sim at power two equal,
which is sort of a powerful simplification tactic basically which you
can use somewhere uh somewhere in the middle of the
proof.
So,
so the main point here is that these are three examples
of,
of you could say programming languages for mathematics,
for writing mathematical proofs in which huge
libraries have been written today,
huge libraries of theorems,
definitions and proofs and all of that is sort of
fully,
fully parsed by,
by these sort of programming languages and also very
securely verified.
So,
so so so the proof is is really,
so the technology has gone crazy recently,
like people re verify,
for example,
the source code of one CRM through in another the RM
through.
So there are layers and layers of security
to make this sort of verification technology as secure as
possible.
Oh,
this is the big uh fly spec project,
the formal proof of the capital conjecture I was mentioning.
So it's this uh nice story from
Prague where uh Kepler was walking in December
from his house,
which is on one side of the Volta River to the Prague Castle
where he was working and he was hit by a snowflake
and he started to wonder why the snowflake has
a hexagonal shape.
And he,
he wrote,
he wrote a nice treatise about it where he,
he does a lot of this conjecture and a lot of this
sort of natural trying to mathematically explain all all these natural
phenomena,
like why the flowers have five petals
or stuff like that.
So he really collects a body of nature
knowledge.
And thus,
it's a very nice exercise in mathematical conjecturing for explaining the nature
of this.
A lot of that is wrong.
But and he actually didn't explain why the snowflake is
there.
And like one of the conjectures which he sort of puts forward there
is this conjecture that the sort of orange pyramid
or cannonball packing of balls is the most optimal
packing of balls in space.
So this had military applications at the time when they wanted to load
cannon balls on a ship,
they really wanted to pack them as tightly as possible.
Um So,
so this has been unproved for 400 years,
as I mentioned.
And uh the American
mathematicians Tom Hall and Sam Ferguson proved it in 1998.
Um sort of using standard Math and a lot of
computational technology.
And basically uh the the the
the review is very completely mm
sort of swamped by by the amount of the material that they had
to verify because the proof is really huge.
And they basically,
after four years of reviewing the proof,
the reviewers who were really good people said,
well,
we cannot verify this proof that this is like we we and out of energy.
So Tom Tom got annoyed by that or
motivated by that and he decided to do the whole proof
of the capital conjecture formally to verify to
using the formal proof assistance.
And this was an effort which took something like 20 to 30 years.
So it was successfully finished in 2014 and it started in
2004,
2003.
And it led to a really a lot of improved technology
and the result is about 20,000 or 25,000
lemmas and the lemmas look like this.
So basically all of that is written in this whole light proof system in this technical proof system.
And you have Lemas like this saying that FS is a polyhedron and C is the face of us,
then C is also a polyhedron and all the LAMAs
sort of build on each other.
And they all of them are approved uh a
brief one slide about what are automated here in the.
So,
so,
so what I was explaining until now are
formal proof assistance,
formal proof checkers or interactive theorems.
That sort of one side of the automated reasoning landscape.
The other side are these sort of good old A I
people who are trying
to write systems which would automatically find
proofs of nontrivial conjectures.
And like as you probably know,
this really goes back to the very beginnings of A I to this sort of good old
fashioned A I people like John mccarthy and
Martin Davis,
etcetera.
So the field has sort of lived its life and
interesting things have been developed although like they
didn't really make it to and somehow they
disappeared from the A I mainstream at some point.
And like today,
the A I is machine learning,
right?
Like that,
that's the,
that's the impression of deep learning we don't even say machine
learning today.
Um But so,
so,
so you have all these systems based on different logical calculus
like resolution superposition tableau satisfiability module theories.
And some of them are really very useful.
For example,
for this field of software and hardware verification.
So that's like the best smt satisfiability
modal theory systems is developed in Microsoft today and they use it for a
lot of software verification.
They are the same holds for Amazon.
There is a lot of such symbolic tools,
the web there for all sorts of these verification tasks and combining them with the
interactive the improvement tools.
So the problem with these tools is that
basically all of that is very much human design
heuristics based on some sort of complete calculus or complete means
that you will find the proof given infinite time.
But the combinatorial explosion there is really
huge.
So typically,
you cannot without very very reasonable heuristics
find even slightly uh more
advanced uh proof.
So basically what we are doing to a large extent is to take such
sort of symbolic tools which do symbolically correct steps
and equip them with some intelligence,
like basically some sort of guidance which will tell them
from this huge number of possibilities.
From this huge combinatorial explosion.
Choose this step because that's the step which will lead you
to the final proof.
Um I will hopefully show you a demo now.
So um so,
so this is uh this is again a mesa
formalization.
So somebody is uh trying to prove
this uh statement um
that if X uh is a,
is a subset of M,
then M is a cardinal here,
that's what you would see if I scroll up but I cannot,
then the cardinality of X is also a subset of M.
So it's a relatively simple mathematical theorem in set
theory.
And what you see there is the um is the human written
me are there.
And uh you can see that this is not horribly
long.
I hope this will work.
So,
so first of all,
what happened is that the system verified it.
So,
so that's when it showed you that there are zero errors,
etcetera.
Uh what should happen?
Hopefully now,
I hope the video works.
Uh So,
so what happens now is that somebody evil removes all the
justifications from,
from the proof?
So,
so at this point,
um we are taking the truth
and we are removing the
steps,
the sort of justifications of the steps which point somewhere to some
huge library saying this is how you justify this step.
And this is how you justify that step.
And instead of that,
they are sort of sending it to some cool A I there which has
learned from all the previous proofs in the library,
uh which,
which recommends the correct lemas and definitions
from the library and basically sends them uh
to an automated theorem improver,
which on,
on these steps is,
is typically able to finish the proof automatically.
So,
so that's um um basically
how,
how the A I research is today helping the
people who are,
who are writing these formal truths,
you sort of give them some unfinished unjustified
lemmas and you unleash the A I to sort of search
over the huge libraries of the facts to
use whatever algorithm to,
to select the most promising ones and
then give it to some symbolic,
symbolic prisoners.
Uh So,
so that's the demo.
Um So I will sort of proceed into
showing you some examples how basically machine learning
and theory improving is,
is combined today.
Uh So,
so there are like various ways how to do.
So what what what you just saw is is basically pres
selecting the correct knowledge from,
from a really large formal corpus by some sort
of pretty simple machine learning and shipping
it over to a black box,
symbolic solver to automated the theory.
So that's very high level because you do the machine learning only once,
basically,
only once when you are choosing,
choosing the knowledge and then you delegate stuff to the automated the theory which would
otherwise blow up horribly.
If you gave to the automated the theory,
a whole library of like let's say 100,000 lemmas and definitions,
then the automated the would do very little.
So um there are similar high level ways of
using some sort of A I or machine learning to assist um theory
improving.
So,
so another one is when you have a very
large number of different theory,
improving strategies,
you can try to learn how which strategies will be good
for which sort of sorts of problems or kinds of problems.
So that's another very high level machine learning task where
again you just do this,
once you select the good strategy or a portfolio of strategies,
and again,
you ship it over and then you don't talk to the solver anymore.
And and another very sort of high level way is when you
have a huge set of flamas used in in the previous booths.
And you there is technology to use the Isla mass as
conjectures for your current proof.
So this technology is called hints.
So you load the hints into your current proof state.
And the situation is that
typically from the previous proofs,
you can load like millions or hundreds of thousands of hens.
And again,
you,
you want to do this in a smart way.
So rather than sort of flooding the theorem two with the wrong
hints,
you want to flood it only with the with the right hints,
the sort of more challenging and also more recent
way how to make some sort of combinations of
learning and theory improving is to really try to influence every low
level step of of the automated the the.
So basically every inference the solver is
doing and that's much more challenging because these
symbolic systems are really,
really fast.
So uh they they do
11 inference per microsecond or like people have been
optimizing the systems forever and written them in all the languages.
So so as soon as you,
as you want to ask some trained neural network or
whatever,
please advise me on the next inference step.
And the neural network takes,
I don't know,
like one 10,000 microseconds or
whatever,
then you clearly have a program like if you are completely right,
then it will work.
But typically you are not completely right.
So you still need to backtrack etc.
Uh So,
so this is much more challenging but also much more,
much more interesting.
And there is interesting research in there and I'll show you some examples,
then there are sort of some sort of combinations
of some sort of compromise between doing things
at a very high level and doing things at a very low level.
So,
so for example,
in these tactical proof assistance,
like whole light the system,
which I which was used for flight back,
you you what you can do instead of like going into the very,
very kernel of the system and the tiny
inferences you can try to learn how to
compose the tactics used,
which are typically some bigger programs
which are often used to sort of structure the proof and to
transform the goals etc etc.
So,
so that's today,
maybe one of the most practically useful things.
So very recently,
we have done things like Monte Carlo research for that,
like combined with some sort of machine learning guidance where it's
really better than just the sort of high level guidance when
you choose the premises in the beginning and ship it over to an automated,
the MP.
And then there are all these things which cannot really be classified too much as some sort of machine
learning.
But they are more sort of A I things like theory
exploration,
which is like you want to develop the theory
to have good new dilemmas and definitions
in it.
Or like there are all these interesting feedback loops when you,
when you prove something you learn from the proof.
Thanks to that,
you sort of get the smarter guidance and the smarter
guidance allows you to prove more problems and that
allows you to learn,
learn more and this can go on and on in these sort of feedback loops.
So to some extent,
it's related to some reinforcement learning um
data sets,
like there are all these large libraries I mentioned
Mizar Isabel Flybe Cock is a very
developed proof assistant used for the formalization of the five Thompson theorem,
et cetera,
et cetera.
Uh So now briefly to the to the various high level,
low level and mid-level methods.
So,
so basically,
uh like 15 years ago,
I sort of started to play with the S Mizar library,
which was really a huge uh biggest library of mathematics at the time
and translated it to be able to give it to automated theorem previous
and to see whether the automated theorem previous can
prove anything at all or whether it's a totally hopeless
task.
So it turns out it is a hopeless task if you,
if you give all the,
let's say 50,000 facts from the library to an automated theory.
Previous,
as I said,
this really blows up extremely quickly.
But um
well,
unlike some people uh who believe that uh uh
selecting mathematical knowledge,
um would think um to,
to be sort of impossible.
Like if you read,
for example,
Penrose,
it,
it really turns out that this is not something
impossible and that there is a clear improvement path.
So like from 2003 to
today,
we can see that the better sort of technology we
put at it,
that the better we can basically select what is the
relevant knowledge for solving a particular
mathematical problem.
And the methods are basically very similar to what people do in some sort of query
answering or natural language um uh answering.
Um So,
so this is one system you,
you,
you basically,
so,
so this,
this is the oldest one when I,
when I just trained a naive base um um sort
of linguistic system to do that.
So you uh so for,
for,
for each proof,
you,
you create a training example from the conjecture.
The conjecture is characterized somehow,
like in this first instance,
it's characterized just by the symbols which are in the conjecture.
And then the proof is characterized just by by the names of the facts which,
which are,
which are used in,
in in the proof.
So so so each proof gives you,
gives you one sort of positive training example,
sort of a multi,
multi label example.
Basically you train your favorite machine lender on that,
like in this case,
it was naive base.
And very surprisingly,
it turns out that already such a simple
solution can give you something like 70%
coverage in the 1st 100 recommended premises.
So let's say if you give to the automated theorem P instead
of let's say 50,000 of all the available facts in your library,
just the 1st 100 then so if you have a
70% coverage of what was actually used in the
human proof.
So that shows you that in some sense,
the formal mathematical corpus is,
is not something crazily undecidable with a lot of
randomness in it.
It's something uh which,
which is constructed by humans in some sense,
similar to what humans do when they write
textbooks and when they write stories,
et cetera,
when they write some sort of scientific treaties
and that there is a lot of predictability there.
So at the time,
if you,
if you gave this to an automated theorem period,
then you could get something like 14% of the library approved fully
automatically.
Today,
we have something like 45 to 50% on these
libraries.
So these are just quickly some some graphs
like from about 67 years ago when we compared the
performance of different machine learning techniques and some heuristic techniques.
So uh the best one,
the blue one which has the best coverage very fast,
very kernel methods at the time.
And obviously today,
you can you can go better with some sort of deep learning methods.
This is another interesting graph like if you combine a
particular machine learning method with sort
of the shelf automated theorem.
And how does the sort of machine learning performance in
selecting the right facts from your library influence the performance of the
of the solver.
So you can see that it's sort of really,
really matters.
So on the y axis,
that's the number of solved problems basically from this particular benchmark.
Oh The um
as I said,
like this is probably the most
industrially used part of what we are doing today.
So the system are called hammers.
So that's a terminology invented by Larry Paulson,
who is the developer in Cambridge of the Isabel system.
So yet the name Sledgehammer,
so you take a problem from an interactive theorem prover
proof a system like Isabel,
the logic is typically richer than just some basic first of logic
which the automated the the work in.
So,
so you need to that that's a reasonably big part of the problem.
You need to translate at least in this scenario,
the rich logic to the sort of more basic logic.
So you create this very solid problem you from the
huge database,
you select the relevant knowledge,
you ship it all to an automated theorem period,
like in this case,
and if the theory finds the proof,
then then you try to reconstruct the proof in the
logic of the interactive the m the sometimes it might fail because there might be some
simplifications when you are doing the translation.
So this has been done in the recent years for basically
all the mainstream interactive the periods and like the
success rate on the top level lemmas in these libraries,
which are typically there are thousands of them.
It's surprisingly for all of them about the same.
So it's about these 45%.
Um so this is quite recent.
So like people are still working on this quite a bit.
So,
so basically the biggest uh issue when you are doing some sort of machine learning
for semantic data for for mathematics,
for formulas and for proofs is to figure out what should be good features of these
data.
Like what what characterizes two formulas
and what distinguishes between very different proofs that you have for
two formulas.
So you can really go pretty wild there.
Like you can use all sorts of syntactic features like the symbols and the terms
there.
But you can also go very semantic like you can pre compute
features which solve some sort of unification or
matching problem there.
You can,
you can really also try to,
for example,
look at at a large number of models in which these
formulas hold or do not hold and take the validity of the formulas in these
models as some sort of semantic characterization of some sort of characteristic
vector,
which you feed to the machine learners.
You can obviously you can try deep learning to do it all for you which sort
of does something but but it's not amazing at the
moment.
As I mentioned,
you can also extract all dilemmas from all the previous
proofs and use them for the current proof.
So then your task is to
deal like instead of tens of thousands of previous knowledge,
you might get millions or even billions of lemmas from the previous
proofs.
And then again,
you need to select from them uh et cetera,
et cetera.
So,
so a very,
one of the very interesting tasks is how to learn from multiple proofs.
So as you probably know like one
theorem or one conjecture in mathematics can,
can have basically an infinite number of proofs and they may
differ in,
in all sorts of ways.
And now if you have a very simple machine learn area,
this might confuse the machine learner.
Uh So,
so how,
how do you,
how do you sort of adjust for that?
How do you make the machine learner take the
advantage of the ability to have really many
different proofs for the same thing and many different ideas
basically.
Um And these are some of the features.
So I will not go into it.
So as I said,
they can be very synthetic,
like the symbols and terms etcetera.
But like you can also also do these very semantic things like
evaluating things in a finite finite model,
evaluating each formula in a finite model,
et cetera,
et cetera.
Oh th th this is one bragging example.
So,
so it's a uh it's,
it's the two which I uh it,
it's the formula of this work.
Oh Yeah.
Um So it's,
it's the formula I mentioned in the proof of uh when I was mentioning P back.
So it's this formula that if C is a S is a polyhedron and C is a face of
S then,
then C is also uh a polyhedron.
And the,
this is a very um well fairly
involved uh technical proof uh written by one of the
masters of formal formal proof basically.
So this will take you really a nontrivial time to,
to,
to do like this.
Uh We basically,
we basically cannot get this proof by an automated theory improver.
Even if we advise the automated theory improver,
what are exactly the facts this proof is using because
the proof is using a lot of stuff and it blows up inside the
automated theory theory.
But the machine learning in this case found that
in the formal library that already have been
developed lemmas which allow to construct the
proof much,
much faster.
So,
so even though the guy who wrote the proof is
sort of a master of formalization.
The sheer size of the library at this time was too much
for him.
And instead of like finding the very easy
proof or reasonably easy proof,
which in this case means basically combining just
44 previous lemmas which are there and like doing some sort
of trick there,
he,
he sort of went down to sort of to expanding the definitions
and,
and doing the,
the,
the sort of carrying out the intuition which he had about it.
Uh Where,
where is the um the,
the machine learner really sees,
sees the whole library like it's,
it's your sort of Google,
right?
Like it can really draw the right uh stuff from the
library.
And uh in this case,
it was sufficiently easy for the automated,
the improver to finish the proof.
So in this case,
we have managed to come up with an easier or
shorter,
shorter proof than the human um a
bit on,
on this low level guidance.
So I,
I'll show you one or two systems
what we are trying to,
to do to really guide a reason when we
are guiding every step.
Um So,
so we took a very simple theorem proving
calculus called connection tableau.
So uh t is this,
it's a tree,
it's a proof tree.
And uh in,
in this calculus you work with clauses.
So um these are all clauses,
clauses are these junctions of literals and
literal is either an atom or its negation.
So I don't know,
like for example,
this one would say out of XY or not P of X or
Qqy,
right.
Um So,
so in connection Tableau,
you sort of start with a.
So,
so,
so all,
all,
all this theory improving in connection tableau
typically proceeds by negating the conjecture and trying to
show that the conjecture together with the negated conjecture together with the X
is contradictory.
So you are sort of trying to infer contradiction.
Um And the way how you show that the,
that the proof tree is contradictory is that basically every,
every path in this tree will contain two
atoms with different sign.
So for example,
you know that pa and not P of A cannot hold together like
that,
that's a contradiction right,
like the same,
same here Q of B and not Q of B cannot hold together.
So,
so,
so when this happens,
when you have a proof tree or a table like this,
you say this is a close connection tableau and you have sort of finish the proof.
So when you,
when you are doing this,
you start with some particular clause and now you are doing operation
called resolution.
That's a sort of an inference that similar to mode respondents basically where
you are sort of connecting,
for example,
this literal,
which was initially this P of X very likely
with this clause.
And then you would get,
you would connect it through the central P and then you would immediately close the branch
and,
but you would open two more branches here.
Um And it's very non deterministic as you can imagine.
So you can extend with all sorts of clauses,
clauses and it usually blows up.
So,
so,
so that's a very,
very simple automated theorem.
The,
the,
the advantage of this very simple setting is that the proof
state is always very compactly represented.
So it's always this relatively smallish fruit tree which you have there.
So if you want to do some machine learning on that,
you have a reasonably compact object on which you can try to do some machine learning.
Uh So,
so we uh we have been trying for
some time uh to do basically machine learning of
choosing the right clauses at the right points of the tableau.
So,
so the first incarnation of the system was this machine learning connection through
or male cop where we just trained a naive base to do it for us.
And unfortunately,
that was really horribly slow at that time.
So,
so the sort of the shelf naive based learner was about 1000
times slower than,
than the inference speed of,
of the,
of the calculus of the uh of the of the resolution uh
step in the tableau.
But already then basically in the number of inferences and the sort of
abstract time we managed to shorten the proof search typically
20 times compared to the brute force search.
So then we did sort of a second version which was this fairly efficient male cop or a
female cop.
And there we related a lot of indexing and a lot of optimizations
and uh we could solve about 15% more problems than
the um than the than the original system,
which doesn't use machine learning.
Very recently,
we have really gone for a stronger
machine learning system.
So in this case,
the reasonably cheap but state of the art um machine learning we use
is XG boost this gradient boost tree.
And instead of sort of staying in
the limits of the original calculus,
we have just plugged in Monte Carlo research there like this standard
um Kish Peshwari formula
where we are sort of learning some sort of policy for choosing
the next step and some sort of value for evaluating the current proof
state.
Like how,
how likely is the current proof state to be completed to
lead to a to a finished proof?
And uh I'll just show you the results.
So we uh we,
we basically do very sort of alpha go alpha
zero style reinforcement learning here.
So we take uh uh we take 32,000 mizar
problems and then we do like
standard 9 to 1 split on them.
So about 30,000 are the training ones and like the remaining
ones are the testing.
So if you use the standard system without any machine learning,
it can do about 10,000 of the of the training funds
and about 1100 of the testing vans.
The very stupid pro without any Monte Carlo guidance is much,
much worse than this sort of hand written standard Tableau
solver,
the Monte Carlo thing without any learned policy and
value is better but still not beating the sort
of human written thing.
But then we sort of plug in the learning.
So from these 7300 training
examples,
we start to learn the policy and the value and we plug it in the
next iterations and,
and we sort of learn and prove and learn and prove in
these whatever 88 iterations.
And you can see that uh like on the testing programs which are
never used for the training,
we get something like 40% improvement over,
over the sort of human human written theorem three.
So,
so even though uh like we,
we still are pretty
beginning when it comes to the technology for characterizing mathematical
data for characterizing the proof state and for characterizing the clauses.
Uh So,
so we did try some deep learning,
but at the moment,
the planning really doesn't help much on,
on this.
It could be that we don't have enough data,
but it's more like uh you,
you need to,
to make deep learning,
more semantic to,
to uh to do something more you,
you can see that was so,
so,
so this is done with hand engineered
syntactic mildly semantic features and you
can already beat the sort of human human written thing here.
A similar.
So,
so there there are the state of the art approvers which work differently than,
than the table.
So pro is one of them,
it's called the saturation superposition style theorem.
So,
so they are basically in instead of working on,
on some proof tree,
these saturation style systems take the Aio and the Neg conjecture
and they turn out lemmas like they infer a new and
new lemas from this initial set of common causes,
hoping to get to a contradiction.
So typically,
in the first one minute,
they would generate like 1 million,
1 million lemmas.
And obviously,
this is a huge blow up and there are some ways how to surf curb it but
not crazy good ones.
So what you can do and what we did and our friends from Google
research also did was basically try to guide
the selection of the next
clause on which you will be doing inferences.
So,
so you sort of at each iteration of this,
the three where you choose one clause from,
from this sort of 1 million and you do all the inferences of this clause
with all the clauses which have been chosen previously.
And if you guide this,
so we guide it by some sort of manual
features and very simple machine learning.
And you can do similar things with deep neural networks,
then we get about 80%
improvement on a particular benchmark.
So even again,
very simple synthetic features,
in this case,
with a bit of semantic engineering can uh can uh
improve the performance at the,
at the moment quite uh uh with Zagger who
might not be here.
OK.
Uh So we uh we recently did
uh something which is sort of a combination of
statistical and semantic guidance of improving.
So,
so,
so that's basically the,
the technology I was mentioning when you load a load of lemmas from previous
proofs into the current proof state and you sort of
prioritize inferences if if you manage to infer
some of some of these previously useful,
useful lemmas.
Oh So in uh
so the sort of contribution there is that we
again,
like we,
first of all,
we statistically um prioritize the
dilemmas and the proofs which we want to load.
But the second improvement there is that the
dynamically inside of the proof search,
we boost those lemmas which are from
the most completed proofs basically.
So we sort of have let's say 100 different
proofs loaded in the current proof search.
And we are sort of jumping from one to the other,
like always greedily trying to complete most of the,
of the one which is most completed,
but at some point,
we might run into trouble.
So we start focusing on the other ones which are less completed.
And this way we are climbing
over the infrastructure imported from the previous proofs.
And of course,
sometimes we need to do some brute force search.
So the brute force search is sort of this slow thinking mode when you have
run out of the previous guidance of the previous ideas,
and you somehow need to connect things to get to something new.
Oh So,
so that's uh also improves improver
quite a bit.
So here is an example from the research.
So we were trying to prove a particular meile
formula which is basically the Morgan loss for bull and let
this not A and not B is not
A or B etcetera.
And uh we,
we can find the proof without the guidance but with the guidance,
in particular,
if we import a proof of a related proof done
in a weaker setting than for hating algebras where you kind of
prove the full the organ but something slightly weaker,
then then the the
proof of of this de Morgan stuff gets uh sort of uh
reasonably uh faster.
And as a benefit of doing this,
like that's been,
I think we have been fighting with for some time,
we get instead of these humongous proof state characterized
by millions of clauses,
we get a reasonable characterization of the proof state of this situation style theorem period.
So,
so at each point of the run of the situation style theorem period,
we have this vector of similarities of the current pro state to the
previous blues and that we are planning to plug it again to the machine
learners uh tactic to that's the probably last
one film from this guiding stuff.
So,
so,
so that's that,
that's a uh that's the tactical mid-level
guidance I have mentioned when you basically no longer translate
your knowledge from some rich rich logic to the
first of automated the the but you do some sort of Monte Carlo,
whatever machine learning guidance inside the interactive theory,
the learning from the previous proofs,
how to apply the tactics to a particular goal and possibly backtracking,
etcetera,
etcetera.
So in some sense,
it's similar to this sort of reinforcement learning in the tableau,
I think in some sense,
it's much more complicated because all the data structures
are much more complicated in the interactive,
the improving I think.
But this is really currently the best working technology
for helping people with automation of their
proofs inside.
So,
so there is quite a bit of interest in doing it for other systems.
So Ya Kashima from my group is doing it for Isabel which is a big
system.
Uh We and some open A I and Berkeley people are doing it for Coke
and we and the Google and some people are trying to do it
for a whole whole life now.
Oh some of these feedback loops.
So I've mentioned some of them already.
So this machine learner for automated reasoning or malaria is
basically this sort of feedback loop.
When you prove something you learn from it,
thanks that you get better guidance.
Thanks to the better guidance,
you get more proofs and you continue to infinitum.
So it can be done in all sorts of ways.
You have to deal with multiple proofs.
You can employ,
you can grow all sorts of additional data structures like
these counter models,
which again help you to characterize your data and
you can do really pretty crazy meta systems.
And typically we regularly beat these other people who don't do machine learning.
So so so far in these A P competitions,
we are the only ones who do some sort of machine learning,
a blind stuff that you maker.
That's probably the last one.
All these automated solvers automated the figures.
If they want to be good,
they have to develop a lot of different
strategies which are parameterized by a lot of parameters.
And the humans who are designing these strategies do
not scale to a large library of very heterogeneous mathematical
problems.
Uh So,
so again,
like we,
you you would like to develop some sort of um automated
in in an automated way,
some population of sufficiently diverse strategies that will
beat the humans in developing these strategies.
So the blind strategy maker is a pun on this blind
watchmaker by doin.
So the strategies are here,
the long connect giraffes which
specialized for eating the very tall problems and
uh the better the particular J for whatever that
specializes for,
for their own problems.
And so by others,
the more time you give them to evolve basically,
right?
So,
um so,
so again,
there,
there is some sort of feedback loop when you are developing the strategies and
evaluating them,
etcetera,
etcetera.
And this gives us something on a,
on a particular mated term proving benchmark gives us
something like 25% improvement.
This is the first iteration of the system since then.
We have done some more.
Um I'm not,
no,
I'm on time.
Yeah,
I'm running out of time.
Uh So I'll like this,
this last topic um which I call automated formalization.
Uh I'll show you hopefully an
example or maybe I'll show you a demo.
That's probably the best thing to do.
Uh Let's see if we can do that.
Uh Yeah,
so,
so what,
what should be automated formalization that there is a lot of informal
mathematics on the archive and like in textbooks,
et cetera.
And currently with the informal math,
we cannot do all this cool stuff that we can do with these formal math libraries
and we would like to obviously.
So,
so basically some four years ago,
we said,
OK,
so let's train Google translate to translate all of archive into,
into a formal proof language,
right?
Un Unfortunately,
at that time,
at least doing Google translate wasn't too feasible because we didn't have the aligned
data like for German and you have a lot of stuff.
We,
we didn't have too much formal stuff aligned with this informal one.
So the first system which I'm showing you here is basically done by informal
by taking the fly spec library and the formal statements
there and making them ambiguous.
And that way we got something like 20,000 aligned pairs of ambiguous
statement and non ambiguous statement.
And then we basically have not a neural network but a
pro grammar which uh which sort of
takes,
which trains on this sort of tree bank.
And then when you give it an example,
it sort of gives you the most prevalent parses,
it sends it to the type checker and to the sort of large
theory theorem figure and the type checker and the theorem period
tells you whether it's true or whether it's false.
So this is what you will,
you will see in this demo.
So somebody is writing these formulas.
Oops.
Um So,
um for example,
somebody,
somebody wrote this sine zero equals Sine
pi.
Um And uh uh it should delete this
plus uh over two.
And uh now you,
you have different interpretations of that's like for example,
the two,
the first two parts is differ by,
by the bracket thing.
And uh I should probably go slightly back here.
Um So the,
but you can see if this thing,
well,
maybe you can see it.
So the top parts which is the most probable according to the bank according
to the probability grammar is actually disproved by uh by the automated,
the where is the,
where is the second one?
Which is actually the correct one can be proved by looking at the
huge knowledge base of mathematics in the library and basically assembling a proof
using this large theory there.
Oh So that's,
I'll probably stop the demo and the
mm So yeah,
this,
this is basically what the demo is showing and I'll skip that
and just mention that in the very
recent time,
like this last half year,
we have also really tried to do neural translation.
So we took it took some engineering but we got like 1
million latex to misar pairs and we fed it
to state of the art neural translation kit and I avoid
it on another 100,000.
So this is how it looks like this is the rendered thing
and this is the Mizar thing and this is the tokenized misa and
tokens late and
um I'll skip this and just show you this.
So,
so this is what detained neural network is is
doing when you,
when you give it a piece of input latex like this.
So so this latex uh corresponds basically
to this formal Mizar sort of statement.
And the neural network is
evaluated every now and then on this sort of testing data as it is
being trained.
So in the beginning,
you can see that the neural meric produces tot total garbage,
it produces some symbols which don't even occur in the
target formula.
But as you train more and more on the data,
the target formula is becoming more and more correct.
And basically the last one is equivalent to the
original one modulo,
renaming of variables,
which is sort of interesting because it got it semantically run despite
uh renaming sequel two to sequel nine and
sequel one to sequel.
So,
so if you,
if you,
if you let it train longer than it actually even gets the names of the variable strength.
But anyway,
the point of this is to show that at least on
this example,
which is slightly synthetic because the latex is sort of generated from the Mizar formulas.
It is not totally
unbelievable that we might be able to
turn a lot of informal late written mathematics into this sort of
formal formal mathematical code which would be really,
really good.
So these are the acknowledgements like a lot of people from Prague,
from Innsbruck,
ITP ITP,
Google people,
etc some references.
And if you are interested,
then come to our A ITP conference in April.
I'd like to be here to start to introduce yourself.
But one of the one of the benefits of organizing a conference is that you barely get to participate in
doing other stuff.
But yeah,
I hope the reason why I wanted to invite Joseph
here is clear,
it's not just that he was my,
my son's thesis advisor.
But also more,
more importantly,
I,
I think there's a two aspects to it.
One is as an application area for a I
that's advancing toward a gi I think mathematics is a lot more interesting
than chess go or a lot of other video games out
there.
I mean,
the branching factor is much larger and I mean,
in a way,
in a way it's a game but it's,
it's a game in the same sense that human civilization is.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a big game which is developed for the creating all the technology that we,
that we have around us and all of our science and so forth.
So,
but yet it's a formal thing that exists inside the computer.
So I,
I think it's a,
it's a really interesting area to experiment with learning reasoning and,
and all the different things we do in,
in,
in a gi I wouldn't say it should be the sole thing that A G I research
work on.
But it,
it certainly is,
it is really an interesting challenge and I'm surprised it doesn't get more
attention that the other thing is for those of us working on A I systems that
incorporate logic as one of the tools.
I think there's a lot of interesting tricks and then maybe more than tricks,
ways of thinking in the augment their improving world that
could be abuse in common sense reasoning as well.
But I see there's not that much communication for people working in common sense,
reasoning and people working in this sort of formal math reasoning.
Of course,
one talk barely hints at all the,
all the stuff underlying it.
But my,
my hope is that there can be more interaction between the two communities and the ways
of drinking and going forward.
And now we're,
we're sort of into the lunch time here.
So we don't have time for lengthy questions.
Maybe we can do a couple of brief questions.
I don't know if you can do a quick,
quick,
quick uh twofold question.
Um What is your take on the unive and foundations?
Will it shorten proofs?
And second,
um how would you compare Cock and Mizar in
terms of practical usability,
especially for us A I folk who are not very experienced in this
stuff?
It's really funny.
So the reason why I wasn't,
in fact was that I was indu at indu seminary on formalization of
mathematics and type theory.
And I gave a slightly differently geared but
propaganda talk about what we are doing.
I got the exact same question from Andre Bauer,
who is one of the guys working on homotopy theory.
So,
so is there any difference for us as the people who are trying to do the A
I for math between,
let's say Mizar Isabel Coco Light and my answer
was at the moment no,
if you want to do feature engineering
beyond some simple symbol term sub the
stuff,
some semantics,
et cetera,
then you will get to it.
Like if you want to go into semantic characterization
of your math objects like formulas and truths,
et cetera,
then you will get there,
you will have some homotopy as your model,
etc,
etc.
But at the moment,
what we are doing is mostly very synthetic and the methods we use
for Misa is a boll hole we use also for Coke.
And the second question was which one you should choose whether
it's Coke or.
So for example,
homotopy theory or uno foundations is specifically geared treatment of
isomorphism.
So if that's important for you,
then you will get a lot of mileage out of using a particular system
which will do a lot of isomorphism computation for you automatically
if you,
if you are not into that,
if you are doing some number theory or whatever you should be watching for other auto
mechanisms,
which are implemented as tactics as sometimes very sophisticated tactics I know in
Isabel or in whole light etc where you have a huge number of
theoretic formalization.
So one way how to see uni and foundation the theory is as
a particular kind of automation geared towards treatment of
isomorphism.
But there is a lot of other automation which you have to do when you are doing
different branches of mathematics.
So um choose your weapons wisely.
So there's a highly rated question on the app that I'm
not sure has a short answer either.
Um this is from David,
it says rather than using automated theorem prover to prove theorems whose statements are
provided by mathematicians,
how much of their capability could be repurposed to derive mathematics
from scratch that is start them off with the Z FC axioms of set
theory.
Then let them derive interesting results or interesting has something to do with the depth and
generality of their implications and perhaps something additional learned from its own
mathematical experience.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
that's a color.
So,
so,
so we had a very interesting discussion about reinforcement learning and like is
math a game at A IP this year.
So David Mistry who is at the Toyota Technological Institute in Chicago
came up with a particular idea of what could
be a general characterization of interesting theory
or interesting theorems and what could trigger this sort of
huge enforcement learning loop start from the scratch and
then have some very basic core criterion for what is
interesting and that would sort of trigger off the research in
mathematics and then you would sort of go down the street.
Uh So,
so,
so I think it's really interesting and people should do research on that,
but we haven't,
we are currently still struggling with the basic tasks
being really too hard for us.
So we are trying to improve on
sort of a rule for what's an interesting,
I hope so,
you can definitely create the database and feed your favorite neural
network to the database.
People have come up with human written criteria of what
should be interesting like Pat Langley and Simon Colton,
et cetera.
Uh But real really doing it the neural way,
the data driven way.
I don't think this has been tried yet.
So.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
Then you can
tell there is a valuation function
there.
Uh It's just just a quick comment.
Um The frequency with which a particular
result is used,
it is a kind of fitness.
Actually,
I think automated mathematician,
the original AM program was something like that.
But say if you plug in particular numbers into a
theorem in number theory,
it's probably not so interesting.
But if you use variables,
it might be.
So that's because it will be reused many times in the future.
So that's probably the right.
So indeed the systems which have been human written have
used like the number of things have been used and the number like the shortness,
for example,
the generality as various features of this
ultimate interesting this formula and you could play with the features with
the weights of these features,
for example.
So that's been done to some extent by Stepan Schulz and Simon Colton.
So just just the usage.
So sometimes the usage is sort of a boring thing because you,
you have some I know reflexivity of equality you used all the time or
symmetry of equality.
So,
so that's not your most important dilemma there.
In some sense,
it's not the most interesting clemma.
At least,
maybe most important,
but not the most interesting
you probably need.
Uh uh that's the measure um because we're
talking about the domain.
So you have to predict how useful is this theorem going to be in
the future.
So that's like density.
Yeah,
I don't know how to predict the future.
Well,
you could,
you could try,
yeah,
there's a problem there because the future depends on the
you,
you could always split that.
That's what we do quite often.
We split the library as it's sort of chronologically developed and then we have a sense of
history and a future.
And so you,
you would have some future.
Well,
the other thing you can do is um presumably you're going to be pruning your
search tree often.
So you can look at not just your prediction as to how much it will be used,
but also how much it has been used and not prune it
with as high a probability if it has been used frequently,
for example.
So definitely like when you are doing some sort of simplest be
learning of this lemma recommendation,
like the number of times it has been used is absolutely a major factor.
Well,
there's this uh intrinsic motivations you might have heard about or not.
Uh but I talked about it before and uh so this is this notion,
it's called empowerment.
It tells you,
it says you should go to a state from where you have like the can reach
the most possible future experiences.
So in math,
I would say you,
you should try to find the theorems that will let you get
the most,
prove the most theorems from,
from having this theorem.
And probably also in the shortest like it,
it should be discounted for how many further,
how many further steps you have to uh use to get to those ones?
Yeah,
but,
but then again,
like you,
you,
you still need some,
some way of saying what,
what will be the stuff you are actually interested in,
right?
So statement only.
Yeah,
that one plus one equals two,
you can get through a lot of experience by adding one to each side.
Um So yeah,
this is,
this is a very interesting discussion.
Entropic force.
Yeah.
Causal entropic forces is,
is,
is just empowerment.
It's the same thing.
Yeah,
it's similar but in,
in mathematics it seems a little trickier than so.
So I I'm I'm having these discussions like now,
now in Pittsburgh,
there were all these mathematicians working on geometry and on the Langlands
program and I'm asking them like,
what,
what's your criterion for an interesting or cool conjecture
or theorem?
And the answer is OK,
it's been long unproved uh right?
Like it's important or it's cool.
Um Well,
that,
that's a weird thing.
Mathematics,
there are some results that some mathematicians.
So sometimes it's really like,
like for example,
the full color theorem people will tell you well,
this is so virtually useless,
but it's been open for such a long time or whatever that when people proved it
then got famous.
And so so then you have LS program which everybody says that it's
extremely deep.
And if they got it,
if they get it,
then the understanding of mathematics will really deeply
change.
But then again,
what does it mean that the understanding of mathematics will really deeply change?
That means that you have some very deep connections and you will be able to transport some results.
And maybe that plugs in to some utility function like you are
describing,
I don't know different things that
humans intuitively think
actually connecting algebra and geometry from a math view.
It's just more manipulation.
We just,
we think it's important to connect space and language we've seen different.
Uh So yeah,
there's what's interesting in terms of the information theory of math and what's
interesting that it strikes human emotions in a certain way and it's not even clear which
one you want.
The A I there's something there
about the unexpectedness of Yeah.
Yeah,
no surprising.
This is definitely surprising this to human
emotion,
has a sort of pure math aspect and has a sort
of human human aspect of four color here seems like it,
it gets us emotionally because that's the colors on.
Whereas maybe an A I mathematician,
it's like,
who gets shit about two dimensions anyway,
there's a dimension.
So I guess we should let and have lunch.
But yeah,
thanks a lot for really interesting.